freunde command nummer drei ist so
unfassbar unfassbar dass man den
überhaupt nicht in worte fassen kann wo
mein gott was wir nur passieren
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
der minecraft commands heute hier am
freitag ist es gestern kein video kam
aber ich bin einfach immer noch mega
kranken angeschlagen haben very very
sorry for data meine damen und herren
deswegen entschuldige ich mich
dementsprechend auch für meine stimme
die gerade so ein bisschen heiser ist
und so weiter und so fort
ich bin aber schon auf dem weg der
besserung er kennt das ja wenn sich dann
engel zu schleimen so löst und so weiter
jeden fall sind wir nicht hier um über
meine krankheiten zu diskutieren sondern
um uns minecraft commands anzuschauen
und da wurde mir heute wieder richtig
richtig coole zugesendet und zwar fangen
wir direkt an mit dem command stimmt
meine lieben freunde das waren command
den ich damals selber sogar mal
vorgestellt habe und zwar habe ich
damals ja mal in den minecraft facts
gesagt ja hier ich habe hier in command
der fügt ein ganzes dorf hinzu ich weiß
nicht wie das ganze jetzt hier ist wenn
hier über all diese komischen bäume
stehen auf dass das dann überhaupt noch
funktioniert also schon wieder extrem
cool aus mit dem shader mit der sonne
und sonne ganz cool also ich gebe hier
diesen befehl eine findet in pace bin
oder so einer beschreibung ganz unten da
könnt ihr euch den befehl dann selber
auch anschauen das selber austesten und
ich klicke ich hier jetzt mal auf dem
schalter und jetzt sehen wir schon dass
hier so ein riesiger turm kreiert wird
er die ganze zeit ihr seht es da es
werden die ganze zeit neue blöcke
geboren neue sachen daran gebracht weil
man einfach so viele sachen dafür
benötigt für diesen kommen ich bin ein
bisschen krank
jedenfalls bekomme ich jetzt einen
schneeball und wenn ich den schneeball
jetzt ich weiß nicht ob es funktioniert
ich schmeiße jetzt einfach mal hier hin
und jetzt sehen wir ich meine ja doch es
funktioniert jetzt sogar noch cooler
weil das jetzt in dem in den bäumen so
drin ist ist es eher buggy ist es auf
den bäumen doch ok freuen ich werde das
ganze natürlich vernünftig zeigen
deswegen werde ich das mal veranlasst
worden wie beispielsweise hier im wasser
was ist wenn ich das im wassersport
kriegt dann ja das ist dann ist es hier
am rand gefahren ok cool ich zeige euch
das jetzt einfach mal hier das ist jetzt
unseren strand dorf und spaß einfach ein
command die ich damals schon mal
vorgestellt hatte ich bin mir echt nicht
sicher woher der romand kam
also ich weiß nicht wer sich den
ausgedacht hat oder so aber ich hatte
den damals mal bei den fans vorgestellt
haben jetzt gedacht als ich jetzt mal
die effektvoll mal durchgegangen bin so
hey da habe ich ja schon command
vorgestellt damals ist der mega cool und
so und zwar ab hier eigentlich hat schon
was er dass er zum baumhäuser mäßig es
kommt auf jeden fall nicht so eine
großstadt mäßig was wir schon mal hat
microsoft commerce von ein paar folgen
sondern es wird so ein kleines dorf
gusborn mit so etwas anderen häuser
texturen beispielsweise kosmos die
kombis down mit zäunen drin mit netter
ziegelstein dächern und so weiter
allerdings auch mit villiger mit dem man
ganz normal dann irgendwie handeln kann
und irgendwelche sachen sich holen kann
das ist natürlich klar allerdings ihr
seht schon das ganze ist ein bisschen
magie also wenn ich eine freie fläche
habe die einfach nur aus sage ich mal
erde und sand und so besteht und dass da
das einfach drauf sporne dann ist es auf
jeden fall nicht so buggy wie jetzt
irgendwie da vorne oder hier dass es so
komisch auf dem boden teilweise
draufsteht was so des cee'd ist übrigens
wieder jedem einige wollen ja hier
manchmal dies haben hier das ist es ist
eigentlich ganz cool vor allem china
sieht ganz cool aus ich werde jetzt dorf
einfach mal hier oben drauf spawn denke
ich weil ja hier oben sehen wir auf
jeden fall schon das ganze ist auf jeden
fall ein bisschen besser kreiert worden
also damit nicht so komische bugs das
ist gut hier steht auch noch auf den
bäumen drauf und so und hier ist es auch
dann darunter gespannt worden
aber ich habe hier einfach keine freie
fläche ziel ist echt ganz nice jetzt
einfach mal so ein wasserbecken da ist
solar war ist ganz cool das war auf
jeden fall command nummer eins und jetzt
kommen auch schon zug nummer zwei der
zwar nicht so was krasses hinzufügen
allerdings schon eine ganz interessante
sache endet wollte das sieht echt aus
wenigen zum rollenspiel wenn man sogar
die komplette welt hinweg schaute sind
so tiefe wälder und alles sieht schon
mega nice aus effekt nur über 2,2 ist
mir zu sehr von von maxi place at und
zwar kommt einfach einen you kann und
wir haben jetzt hier eine duke in
minecraft das ist einfach dieser command
zusammen feiern bau dann einfach dass
der hall bei den werten 255 also mehr
oder weniger über 100 ist dann runter
flieg explosions power dass ein paar
sachen gemacht und dann fliegt hier
quasi von unten einfach sondern so ein
riesiger drewes ding runter lässt die
sachen anfängt anfangen dann verknüpft
ist die sachen hier auf jeden fall auch
anfangen zu brennen und so weiter und so
fort und ihr seht schon alter mit dem
shader wenn ich in feuer drin stehe
das ist teilweise so ein bisschen und
schafft wenn nicht die pferde
feuerwerker ihr seht schon das ding
macht auf jeden fall mega viel schaden
und vor allem auch wenn ich das bei
einer flachen fläche mal mache ich weiß
nicht hier sieht man das nicht so gut
aber da gehen echt wirklich wie bei
sondern juso streifen in die äußeren
wirkungen rein
ich versuche euch das war jetzt
irgendwie hier mal kurz zu zeigen weil
das ist echt solle welt da hier ist nix
flach hier ist alles nur gebirgig ich
versuche hier noch mal eben empfiehlt
der feier boller und jetzt runter und
wir sehen schon kann ich echt schlecht
zeigen wir dieser will ich mal mit den
flächen einfach das sind die richtung
noch mal so ein streifen wer geht in die
richtung in die richtung wie sonne
sonnenschein mehr oder weniger und da
fängt dann auch alles an zu explosiven
explodieren und zu brennen und so und
das ist auf jeden fall der command
nummer zwei ganz simpel fügt einfach
eine riesige explosionen zu einem ewf
mehr oder weniger lässt ja alles
anfangen anfängen anfängt zu brennen
ich meine sogar die new media projekt
war noch um einiges größer wir auf jeden
fall interessante sache für den oder der
letztes mal nachgefragt habe ganz oft
genug geben ja freunde command nummer
drei ist so unfassbar unfassbar dass man
den überhaupt nicht in worte fassen kann
ist es wirklich so mit einer der
krassesten commands die ich je gesehen
habe und ich weiß das sag ich dazu jeder
folge habe ich entdecke halt immer
wieder neue sachen und zwar geht dieser
command über sage und schreibe irgendwie
100 zeilen oder noch mehr ist mir zu
gesendet worden nicht von dem von dem
typen der den kopf gemacht hat an sich
allerdings von ganz vielen anderen die
beiden soja hier guck mal hier der und
der hatten supertoll command gemacht
schau dir nochmal ich drücke jetzt erst
mal drauf und ihr seht schon da werden
wieder mega viele
romands gemacht und ich krieche wieder
whatsapp nachricht von dem fvd hey ich
bin jetzt hier und hier will was uns
jetzt mal aufnehmen ja und zwar freude
mir das video gesehen dass herr freytag
und ihr werdet morgen einen real live
video mit dvd sehen uns da was tolles
verlegte challenge und wir werden die
renten auch wer wenig machen und so also
dass auf jeden fall ich verpassten auf
mein mann auf seinem kanal
das war sind mit der werbung mit pkw
zurück auf kuba und zwar wird mit diesem
command einfach diese maschine hier
gemacht mehr oder weniger ich mal ebend
10 wir sind ja schon wieder so ein
bisschen über dem limit
und zwar habe ich mir gedacht meine
lieben freunde dieser folge nicht wie
normalerweise aus fünf besteht sondern
nur aus drei und zwar bekommen wir diese
maschine und ihr seht schon der command
ist von maxxim wachstumskraft 24
allerdings genauer bekannt unter chaos
flow 44 kennen meine ich einige ich
kenne die beispielsweise auch und ich
kann jetzt hier einfach mal rein klickt
ist ein typ der die teams klick jetzt
werden alle meine sachen ausgetauscht
durch diese sachen die ich jetzt hier
habe zwei bücher beispielsweise
unstoppable boots die kann ich mir mal
anziehen und jetzt nur noch
beispielsweise firewall und ihr seht
nicht ab resistenz direkt teilung
sättigung alle möglichen sachen bin
extrem gut hier mit den sachen mit dabei
und so weiter und so fort das heißt wenn
irgendwas passiert oder etwas explodiert
kriege ich auf jeden fall schon mal kein
schaden also die rüstung des mega gut
und ich habe hier noch mehrere waffen
bekommen und zwar beispielsweise heraus
und wenn ich jetzt hier mit mit dem fall
ganz normale kuh abschießen will schon
ich habe ich getroffen
ich schieße die kuh ab und ihr seht
schon da passiert ja gar nichts mit
außer dass der pfeil irgendwie so
komisches firework um sich dann aber
wenn ich mal auf den boden hier schießen
sehen bekommt einfach einen tnt und
einer explosion die freunde bogen
gespannt runterlassen und ihr seht schon
eine explosion und ein feuer
wenn ich jetzt wie beispielsweise
einfach mal ein bisschen rum travel.de
da kommt mega viel firework und auch ein
paar explosionen auf jeden fall will den
staat also das ist das was ich mit
diesem feilen hier machen kann
danach habe ich hier eine bombe bett
eine fledermaus also ihr seht schon
freuen und warum mache ich das was ich
heute nur drei nehme ich möchte nicht
dass das video irgendwie 20 30 minuten
lang wird weil ich heute echt wieder
wenig zeit habe und dieser command endet
ja quasi mehr oder weniger der dead 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 items wo wir dich alleine
schon eine komplette folge machen könnte
schaut auf jeden fall mal bei dem chaos
flow vorbei das ist ein richtig geiler
command und ja ich zeige euch erstmal
die bombe bett und zwar gehe ich einfach
drauf da kommt eine feder boss die
brände die denkt euch sowieso nichts
besonderes oder ganze plakat
naja die drobs ab und zu so ein bisschen
tnt ist macht die meine ich drei mal so
da kommt das nächste tnt du bist der
boss adidas tnt explodiert und jetzt
lässt sie meine ich nochmal alles fallen
jetzt verschwindet die fledermaus und da
habe ich schon das dritte tnt also
einfach die bomber fledermaus mehr oder
weniger
dann haben wir hier einen instant feier
cracker was genau der bringt weiß ich
nicht genau ich weiß jetzt das feuer ist
was der kreiert oder ob der auch
irgendein staat macht dagegen welche
kühe oder tiere allgemein das können wir
aber eben einfach austesten
ich setze ihn einfach mal hier neben ok
anscheinend schon anschein macht er doch
ganz schön guten schaden ja also dass es
dann einfach seine
komische wird übrigens mega leid dass
ich einfach zu dieser zeit durch den
durch die nase spreche und so keine
ahnung weil ich einfach so ein bisschen
krank bin aber das wird hoffentlich in
den nächsten videos besser sein also das
ist einfach ein instant feier cracker
also der einfach so feuer direkt macht
und ihr seht schon derart extremen guten
schaden der kann die leute auf jeden
fall die mobs direkt töten und so weiter
und so fort also das ist quasi and fire
cracker finde ich aber jetzt nicht sooo
geil
das heißt nicht geil ist es natürlich
schon geil aber es ist jetzt nicht so
geil wie die anderen sachen die ich euch
jetzt vorstelle und zwar habe ich hier
noch eine n will bob und zwar kann ich
den hier einfach mal hinsetzen und ihr
seht schon das schaf ist tot und es
werden überall in wiltz platziert also
ambosse hier seht ihr es noch mal ich
setze hier von patenten fische hindi
bleiben jetzt habe ich auch sofort
zugegriffen
ihr seht schon die kommt und richtig
viele ambosse aber wenn ihr euch dann
denken dass so viel an bord ich komm mit
vielen börsen gerieten dann könnt ihr
einfach dieses ding dem das ist ein
schwein und das ruft an die ambosse
zumindest in der umgebung im umkreis
wenn ich hier mal drauf klicken
beispielsweise alle wurden verletzt die
beiden dann kann ich hier noch mal so
schön setzen ist der weg kann ich jedoch
wahrscheinlich letzten endes der weg und
da hinten gar nicht an beispielsweise
tomaten schweinchen hinsetzen und das
ist er auch das sind alles so sexy quasi
irgendeine wirkung haben und jetzt will
ich das aller coolste ist die mighty
skript bond suite bombe und zwar ist es
einfach ein tintenfisch der sich dort
dreht ihr hört schon komische sounds und
jetzt seht ihr auch die im moment dreht
sich immer schneller schneller fdp gott
was wird passieren er geht ganz hoch und
er fliegt nach unten und es explodiert
habt ihr die blitze gehört freunde so
geht das geht bis zum fucking redstone
ich werde hier einfach mal noch mal noch
eine skript noch eines kommt noch eines
mit point mochte skript sprit wird
wichtiger als dieser zum rächer
freunde ich bin gerade auf dem boden vom
einschlag der bomben
es ist unfassbar krass was die fünf
schaden macht entschied sich aber bisher
ohne jedoch mal der explosion waren uns
war das alles fügt mega krasse sachen zu
freuen und ich denke jetzt wisst ihr
auch wieso ich das video heute nur mit
3,1 gefüllt hatte sonst hätte es
wirklich einfach den rahmen gesprengt
ich bin jetzt schon mal zehn minuten
aufnahmezeit oder so also bei 16 minuten
anstatt das immer so ein bisschen runter
mit bearbeiten allerdings wenn ich euch
jetzt noch zwei kurz vorstellen würde
wäre es viel zu lang und ich würde gar
nicht hinkriegen das ganze noch zu
bearbeiten
deswegen hoffe ich dass sie auch heute
mit 3,1 zufrieden seid und ihr findet
selbstverständlich die command wieder in
der beschreibung ich würde mich freuen
wenn ihr dem video eine bewertung da
lässt last wäfler weil ich dann mal mit
der bearbeitung schon so ein bisschen
dran sitze deswegen würde ich mich
darüber freuen wenn ihr konzept in der
beschreibung findet ihr ein commands
formular
dort könnt ihr entweder eure eigenen
oder kommerziellen videos gesehen habt
oder irgendwo anders
ich möchte euch einfach nur die sachen
vorstellen die ich selber auch cool
finde und dann sehen wir uns in einem
nächsten video wieder